been waiting all afternoon this was the
reaction from the scientist
okay so this is live picture that was
searched just a few moments ago they had
released a picture of erlenberg earlier
on of the separation from the mothership
Rosetta and the Falaise spacecraft that
had to go and try and land on comet 67p
Robert Nesbitt is at the European Space
Agency in the German city of Darmstadt
looks as though it's gone according to
plan absolutely these are extraordinary
scenes out they it was fairly muted this
morning when they first realized that
separation had happened that this mini
spacecraft had left the orbiter and was
heading towards the comet but
progressively throughout the day as each
hurdle arguably a higher hurdle has been
cleared they've been more and more
demonstrative and that was an absolute
cry of joy you saw Paolo ferry who is
the mission director has a lot riding on
this obviously leaping up punching the
air and hugging his his colleagues it
means in effect that that dishwasher
sized spacecraft that was flung at this
spinning comet has landed now where it
is landed whether it's landed on a clear
ground which is what they wanted or or
rocky slightly more difficult terrain
for it to anchor itself to we're going
to have to wait for more data to come
back but in effect what has happened now
is the spacecraft has landed on the
comet it's sending information back to
the orbiter and the orbiter is sending
that information 300 million miles back
to here in Germany and we've got that
confirmation now